遊戯！今日こそ金を持ってきたか！？
やめてよ城之内くん
やめてよ
おまえ今日こそわかってるんだろうなぁ
やめてよ城之内くん
はやく金だせよ!
分かってんのか遊戯！
はぁ・・はぁ・・・
わかったよ城之内くん
あぁ・・城之内くん
ありがとよ遊戯
城之内くん・・
やめてよ
おい遊戯
JOYSOUNDの会員カードしか入ってねえじゃねえかよ
ごめんよ城之内くん
ぼくは・・・・歌が好きなんだ
ふざけんなよ
ジョーノーチくん！
うああ・・
なにすんだ城之内くん
うああああ
ジョーノーチくん！
うあああ・・ジョーノーチくん！
グハッ!!
うああ・・・
遊戯
次までに金を用意しとけよ！
く・・・
僕が・・
弱いから・・・
相棒・・・
はっ！
はっ
うわああ！
なんだこれは！
何が起きているんだ！
うわっ
うわあああああ！ジョーノーチくぅぅぅぅーん！
いくぜ・・・相棒
そう・・・この時遊戯の中に眠るもう１人の遊戯が目覚めてしまったのだ
俺の魂のカード
城之内くん
デュエルだ
おまえ・・
遊戯か！？
探したぜ
城之内くん！
城之内くん！デュエルだ！
いいだろう遊戯
受けて立つぜ
いくぜ城之内くん！
おれのターン！
ドロー！
おれは！JOYSOUDの・・・
もう１人の僕
相棒！
だめだ・・
遊戯王カードはルールが難しくって見てるみんながわからない
もっと簡単なゲームで勝負するんだ！
なるほど
そういうことか・・相棒
なんだと！？
城之内くん
立ち相撲(押し相撲)で勝負だ！
♪てってれてっててててって♫
デュエル！